Hugh Jackman and his wife are divorcing
after 27 years of marriage I really like
Hugh Jackman and he's always struck me
as a nice guy compared to the demons
running around Hollywood he seems
relatively normal and grounded and sort
of nice and he's just all around seems
like a decent fellow and so it's very
sad that this guy one of one of the
things that really spoke to his
character is that he had been married
for 27 years by Hollywood standards that
is an eternity that is
the longest marriage ever a spokesman
for the the jackmans say that the
writer's strike has contributed to it
because they've been stuck around at
home a little bit more I guess and the
the pandemic the lockdowns and this is
really really sad too how many marriages
broke down because of this
how many when you upend all of the norms
and routines of society things are going
to break things did break economically
politically but all the way down to the
family